bonsoir et bienvenue en ce lundi 23
février pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale il est l'heure du
journal de la rédaction voici les
principaux titres les mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste ce referme de
l'organisation aux performances des
Français nous sommes avec François voilà
de l'organisation aux performances des
Français nous allons revenir sur le
succès avec en plateau le directeur
général délégué à la compétition à nos
courtiers vous entendraz aussi le
champion installé dans les ivelines
François Pervis nous parlerons également
de deux ateliers qui se déroulent
pendant les vacances un atelier manga
sur la verrière à la médiathèque et puis
également des ateliers autour du cirque
c'est à la Bergerie Nationale à
rombouiller ARN courtier bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes le directeur général
délégué au championnat du monde de
cyclisme vous allez nous accompagner
pour cette ce début du journal pendant
long pendant un long moment on va
dresser le bilan de cet événement côté
sportif côté organisation côté sportif
déjà la France qui termine en tête du
classement des médailles C médailles
d'or deux médailles de bronze c'est même
au-delà des objectifs c'est une très
belle opération sur un plan sportif sur
un plan sportif c'est une opération
magnifique je crois que les athlètes
comme le directeur technique national
Vincent Jaquet sont tout simplement
heureux il n'y a pas d'autrre mot euh
c'est pas réellement une surprise on
savait qu'ils étaient prêts je crois
qu'avoir pu
participer à cette compétition chez eux
à domicile dans leur Vélodrome a
évidemment été un élément essentiel et
leur a donné envie de se surpasser
peut-être un mot par rapport au tout
dernier résultat encore hier de François
Pervis il a été éliminé en quart de
finale de vitesse individuelle mais par
un autre Français greégoryi boget il n'a
pas réalisé le triplet comme àali l'an
dernier il quitte tout de même les
Mondiaux de 5tin avec deux titres
François Pervis était heureux vous avez
changévec ou oui il était très heureux
deux titres sur trois ce qu'il a fait
l'année dernière était extraordinaire
exceptionnel trois titres mondiaux
c'était fantastique il en garde deux
c'est aussi fantastique et il est très
heureux au total ce sont déjà ces six
sacres mondiaux pour François Pervis
dans sa carrière le palmarès du français
qui s'éoffe de compétition en
compétition les victoires de ces
derniers jours ont forcément un goût
particulier puisque ce sont des
victoires à domicile il est dorén avant
installé à montinil bretonux c'est
Michel elmidoro qui l'a rencontré au
bord de la piste nous sommes avec
François Perville double champion du
monde ici à saint-quenttin envine alors
de tites champion du monde c'est c'est
vraiment extraordinaire oui ououi parce
que c'était loin d'être gagné euh comme
je vous l'avais annoncé il y a quelques
semaines ma condition physique était pas
bonne du tout j'ai fait en conséquence à
l'entraînement donc c'est quoi la
conséquence c'est très très peu
d'entraînement donc quand on s'entraîne
très très peu on retrouve de la
fraîcheur mais c'est pas du tout une
préparation optimale pour pour atteindre
une forme au top donc
bah c'était dans la tête quand même pas
facile à gérer parce que je me dis je me
disais
que je faisais un tiers de ce que je
devais faire pour arriver au top de ma
forme et il fallait simplement que je
retrouve de la fraîcheur donc fallait
choisir et le choix était dur mais
j'avais pas le choix que de faire que de
la fraîcheur et donc je vous dis je
reviens de loin et j'en suis très très
content il y a pas un petit regret sur
cette dernière course avec Grégory si
forcément il y a un gros regret parce
que je gagne tout de suite la première
donc j'ai montré que physiquement et
mentalement j'étais là les gens me
répondaient bien mais j'ai J'ai trop
fait d'erreur tactique
et j'ai pas assez pratiqué la vitesse
individuelle cet hiver et j'ai pêché par
mon de pratique
et en face Ctait Grégory Boger donc
c'est pas n'importe qui donc il était
opportuniste et puis voilà ça ça m'a
coûté certainement une médaille et
pourquoi pas la conservation de mon
titre et ce public du Vélodrome un petit
mot sur pu V Rome il est il est
extraordinaire un petit mot j'ai pas
envie de dire un petit mot j'ai envie de
dire un grand merci parce que c'est
c'est exceptionnel c'est vraiment
incroyable tous les jours c'était
c'était bondé même les jours de semaine
euh moi j'ai eu le droit à une dizaine
de tours ils ont fait la haa pendant une
dizaine de tours je jour ça fait
vraiment chaud au cœur le dernier virage
dans mon kilomètre j'étais planté de
chez planté je tirais le frein à main et
si j'ai gagné c'est vraiment grâce à eux
parce que mon mon dauphin il est à 8
cenè de de secondes derrière moi vous
pouvez même pas vous imaginer 8 cenè ce
que ça représente c'est rien du tout et
il y aurait pas
public sincèrement j'aurais pas gagné
c'est vraiment eux qui ont fait la
différ dans le dernier tour et vraiment
je les remercie
et vivre des moments comme ça la
Marseillaise chanter la Marseillaise
avec tout le monde c'est les plus beaux
moments de ma carrière et vous avez
senti que vous changez de statut
vraiment vous avez fait la double page
première page à l'équipe vous sentez
vraiment que vous changez de statut
faire de jours de suite la première page
de l'équipe c'est pas rien c'est pas
rien c'est c'est une fierté quelque part
j'en suis très content et bah voilà
c'est ça tire le cyclisme sur piste vers
le haut le vélodrome aussi depuis qu'il
est construit on fait que d'en parler
nous on voit vraiment la différence
parce qu'il y a beaucoup plus de médias
qui viennent nous voir toutes les
semaines à l'entraînement moi je suis
énormément sollicité depuis mon tripl
l'année
dernière les partenaires viennent vers
moi les sponsors viennent vers moi alors
qu'avant fallait les démarché puis
c'était toujours des réponses négatives
donc les choses changent les choses
changent et ça fait du bien et voilà
c'est ce qui nous fait gagner ça nous
fait gagner et à un an des Jeux
Olympiques ça nous tire ça tire tout le
monde vers le haut et on rentre dans une
dans une are où le cyclisme sur piste
retrouve la
dimension qu' doit avoir et c'est très
bonne augur pour les jeux un petit mot
aussi vous êtes à domicile ici à mon
Bret oui je suis vraiment à domicile
puisque j'habite à 500 m avant le
d'oiseau vous habitez où exactement
alors exactement j'habite à rue Gustave
eel donc il y a des gens qui me
reconnaissent dans ma voiture parce que
j'ai une voiture stickée avec mon nom
dessus
et ce qui m'a fait plaisir aussi c'est
j'ai
été à la poste et puis dans une dans une
dans un chez un marchand d'imprimante et
il m'a tout de suite reconnu et bon je
venais c'était l'année dernière je
venais juste d'arriver je vienis juste
d'emménager il m'a reconnu et voilà
j'étaéis surpris parce que d'habitude on
me reconnaît pas et puis bon
là là on va plus vous reconnaître just
bah surtout que depuis une semaine il y
a ma tête placardée sur toutes les
affiches sur tous les les arrêts de bus
et et les panneaux publicitaires donc
c'est c'est super puis moi j'habite
vraiment au centre où il y a le le
centre commercial et tout ça donc il y a
beaucoup de passages il y a beaucoup de
monde et euh vous allez plus passer une
aperçue ouais is des fois c'est mieux de
passer une aperçu je vous jure c'est
c'est mieux mais après c'est c'est c'est
une reconnaissance et ça fait vraiment
plaisir ça fait chaud au cœur merci
beaucoup François Pervis et que
pensez-vous des performances de François
Pervis c'est notre question du jour
micro trottoir signé aujourd'hui William
l il y a deux médailles d'or j'ai
entendu c'est ça je me trompe pas il a
gagné deux courses il a gagné kilomètres
et le le kine ah oui puis il a raté sa
troisème médaille c'est plutôt une bonne
chose non toute façon bon c'est vrai que
c'est ça fait parler comment dirais-je
positivement de la la ville de 50 an
livel bah c'est bien
pour il représente au moins sa région
quoi au moin on parle de nous à la télé
et François Perville je l'ai vu gagner
vendredi après-midi et ça vous a fait
quoi justement de oh bah très fier très
très fier j'ai vu que il habitait la
région alors que c'est un mayénnais
d'origine mais apparemment il s'est
installé ici ouais d'accord bah écoutez
c'est c'est un petit plus encore quoi et
puis en espérant qu'il aura d'autres
médailles au JO par exemple nous
revenons au cours de ce journal sur ces
mondiaux de cyclisme avec notre invité
Arne courtier directeur général délégué
au championnat du monde de cyclisme on
en parlait tout à l'heure performance
exceptionnel pour les Français est-ce
que d'une certaine manière c'est lié à
l'organisation aussi est-ce que vous
avez été au petit soin pour pour ces
coureurs euh c'est c'est l'encadrement
de la D qui est au petit soins pour les
coururs mais effectivement ils se sont
occupés de parfaitement l'organisation y
est peut-être pour quelque chose on a
essayé de leur délivrer des beau
championnats du monde organiser le mieux
possible dans leur Vélodrome qu'ils
connaissent bien pour qu'il sentant
confiance et puis surtout le public
était là le public était au rendez-vous
nombreux on l'a dit c'était complet tous
les jours et surtout connaisseur vivant
et a soutenu l'équipe de France au
maximum des possibilités on l'a entendu
tout à l'heure François Pervis qui
disait ce titre ce deuxième titre il l'a
remporté grâce au public he dans le tout
dernier tour du côté de l'organisation
justement qu'on précise un petit peu les
choses vous n'avez eu que 6 mois pour
vous préparer à peine comment ça s'est
passé ça s'est passé vite mais ça s'est
très bien passé parce qu'on a eu 6 mois
seulement c'est vrai mais toutes les les
équipes de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme été très motivé évidemment par
cet événement les équipes qui gèrent le
vélodrome la société vélopolice aussi et
puis particulièrement les équipes de la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans de
niveline qui nous ont accompagné qui
nous ont soutenu qui nous ont qui ont
travaillé avec nous quasiment à
pleintemps et c'est grâce à cette
coorganisation qu'on a pu relever le
défi d'organiser ces Championnat du
Monde en 6 mois seulement sachant que ce
n'était pas arrivé en France depuis 2006
he comption c'était bord en 2006 donc
vous étiez scruté regarder il fallait
que que tout se déroule sans accro il
fallait que tout se déroule sans accro
d'autant plus que le vélodrome national
est neuf on recevait un championnat du
monde seulement un une petite année
après son ouverture donc on avait
vraiment à cœur de montrer au monde
entier la qualité de cet équipement et
je crois que de par les résultats le
record du monde aussi batttu par par les
Australiennes on a réussi à assoir la
réputation internationale de cette piste
une très belle compétition on va
continuer à parler de l'organisation on
fait juste un dernier point sur les les
résultats justement résultats obtenus
par ces français des Championnats du
Monde exceptionnels pour les
tricolors 5 titres sur 19 possibles et 7
podiums au total la France s'est
illustrée lors de ces mondiaux de
cyclisme poussé par son public elle a
atteint les sommets dès le premier jour
de compétition et les preuv de vitesse
par équipe Michel dalmedda Grégory boget
et Kevin Siro médaille d'or devant les
néozélandais est disqualifié pour un
passage de relais hors zone ça fait
depuis 2011 qu'on vaer cher chez ce
titre on tourne autour et là de sur
croix être à la maison avec un public
comme il y avait c'était vraiment
satisfaisant j'avais couru en 2006 aussi
où il y avait le même ambiance à
Bordeaux et là d'être à la maison sur
notre piste d'entraînement de tous les
jours et de voir ce public et de monter
sur la première marche c'est c'est
mouvant quoi c'est c'est pas une fin en
soi mais presque donc voilà on va pas
bouder notre plaisir aujourd'hui on est
champion du monde on est meilleur on a
on a ce si beau maillot sur nos épaules
donc voilà on va on va en profiter les
mondiaux sont lancés et la France mise
sur orbite viennent par la suite les
titres de kokar et de kneski dans la
catégorie de
l'américaine et que dire de la victoire
de greégory beet né à maison la fit
livelinois à 30 ans décroche un 4è titre
de champion du monde de vitesse une
victoire particulière lui qui en 2011
avait perdu ce titre pour un manquement
au contrôle antiopage c'est la première
fois que autant de personnes de ma
famille sont un championnat du monde
donc très très très content très ému
j'ai revu Florian Rousseau aussi qui
commentait pour la télé Arnaud Tournant
et des amis du sport aussi qui sont
venus je pense à la Jidou couré les skid
Jaun voilà non c'était très bien d'avoir
un événement comme ça chez nous je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui qui
vont nous suivre jusqu'au Jeux
Olympiques les tricolores qui
engrangeent aussi deux médailles de
bronze avec Julien Maurice sur la
poursuite et Quentin lafarg sur la
vitesse j'ai jamais fait tournoi de
vitesse international et enfin voilà
c'est ouf c'est un peu dingue et
ouais je pense que le fait d'être ici a
beaucoup joué maintenant ça me permet de
de croire en moi encore plus pour les
années à venir mais la star de ces
Mondiaux c'est C homme François Pervis
le PISTAR n'est plus qu'àun titre
mondial du record man français Daniel
Morellon cette couronne dans les années
6070 François Pervis nouvellement
installé à 50 ans en Yveline et qui a
fait de ce Clairfontaine du cyclisme sa
résidence second
REP avec de titres supplémentaires lui
qui était à de doigts de ne pas se
présenter vise maintenant les Jeux
olympiques de 2016 voil on progresse on
bien on sait où on va donc on a fait un
très beau championnat du monde et on a
montrer à tout le monde que on
savait SAV pour les Jeux Olympiques on a
vraiment pas peur on a pas
peur on sait où on va et on a confiance
en tout le monde se point noir de cette
compétition l'absence de médaille chez
les dames
compétition à guichet fermé plus de 5000
spectateurs qui étaient présents chaque
jour c'est une surprise tout de même non
malgré tout dans cet écrin tout neuf du
Vélodrome non non c'est pas une surprise
on a fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour que
le vélodrome soit complet à commencé par
une politique tarifaire très attractive
des tarifs réduits pour les licenciés
pour les cquantinois l'objectif était
d'avoir un stade plein à
craquer c'était le cas et dès
l'ouverture de la billetterie à peu près
65 % des billets ont été vendus dans les
2 premières heures de mise en vente on
savait que ce serait complet très très
vite et c'est la une récompense de la
politique de la Fédération française de
cyclisme et de la volonté toujours de
rendre ce sport populaire et accessible
au plus grand nombre mais les
spectateurs venaient de toute la France
et même audelà ou aussi beaucoup de
cinquantinois alors beaucoup de
cquantinois c'est une vraie satisfaction
beaucoup d'entre eux ont découvert le
vélodrome ils l'avaient vu de
l'extérieur mais ne le connaissaient pas
de l'intérieur et puis beaucoup de
supporters qui sont venus de province
aussi des vrais fans qui ont fait des
bus qui se sont tassés dans les voitures
pour certains mais qui sont venus
soutenir leur champion puisquon parle de
l'organisation avec vous puisque vous en
étiez en charge organiser un tel
événement ça signifie quoi quel quel a
été votre travail au quotidien pendant
cette compétition organiser un tel
événement ça signifie coordonner
beaucoup de de gens mon équipe des
prestataires extérieurs l'aspect sportif
le chronométrage la logistique la
nourriture beaucoup beaucoup de choses
dans le respect des normes et du cahier
des charges de l'UCI puisque un
championnat du monde est tout à fait
normé bien évidemment euh c'est un vrai
plaisir de le faire et pour ce qui est
pendant la compétition
c'est de surveiller que tout se passe
bien finalement d'être un petit peu
partout en même temps et de s'assurer
qu'il y a pas de souci est-ce que tout
s'est bien passé vous en êtes satisfait
est-ce qu'il y a des choses à améliorer
encore nous en sommes très satisfaits
toute l'équipe il y a toujours des
points d'amélioration on va faire les
les débrief cette semaine et puis on va
repartir pour l'avenir et réfléchir à ce
qu'on pourrait peut-être envisager dans
les années qui viennent comment vous
avez vécu vous cette compétition quel
souvenir vous allez en garder écoutez un
souvenir merveilleux je pense que
pendant la finale du Kirin de de
François Pervis où je me suis surpris à
être debout sur le siège dans les
tribunes en train d'hurler c'était un
très bon souvenir que va devenir
maintenant ce ce vélodrome on va parler
des Jeux Olympiques 2024 parce que là
aussi il y a un véritable en jeu le
vélodrome peut-il faire partie du
dossier de candidature le dossier Paris
2024 est en tout cas en cours
d'élaboration et pour accélérer les
choses la communauté d'agglomération de
50 ans neline a donné son soutien
officiel une lettre vient d'être envoyée
à la mer de la capitale àidalgo
rappelons que dans ce dossier figure
également le Golf National qui va qui
organise chaque année l'Open on écoute
Michel logier le président de
SaintQuentin en lil à l'heure où on
cherche des financements ben nous nous
apportons des équipements déjà existants
on a prouvé qu'on était capable de
pouvoir organiser de grandes
compétitions nous sommes en plein
championnat du monde de cyclisme surpce
donc on est dans cette capacité à
accueillir ce type de manifestation nous
organisons avec la Fédération Française
de Golf l'Open de France toutes les
années sur donc le Golf National et nous
allons accueillir en 2018 la Rader club
de golf c'est-à-dire la plus grande de
compétition de golf au monde donc
aujourd'hui le territoire est en
capacité de pouvoir accueillir de
grandes manifestations donc nous tenons
à le dire à Madame le Maire de Paris
l'idée c'est que notamment sur le BMX
sur le VTT et sur le cyclisme sur piste
et bien tout puisse se passer à 550 en
Eveline forcément il y aura Desbat sur
sur la route mais qui peut-être faire
aussi le traain d'union entre l'ensemble
des territoires et bien puisse avoir
finalement toutes ces épreuves ici sur
ce territoire dont on voit bien
l'investissement qu'il y a eu en faveur
du cyclisme et qui doit pou pouvoir
trouver bien son aboutissement dans
l'aventure olympique Paris 2024 les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris en 2024 avec le
Vélodrome avec le golf également qui va
organiser entretemps parce qu'il y a
l'Open chaque année mais il aussi cette
rider Cup compétition entre les
meilleurs européens les meilleurs
américains ce sera en 2018 tout ça c'est
possible les les Jeux Olympiques 2024
avec ces deux équipements oui c'est
possible 5quentin en evveline est prête
à accueillir les Jeux olympiques le
vélodrome vous l'avez dit effectivement
on vient de faire la semaine dernière la
démonstration de sa la capacité à à
recevoir des événements internationaux
le Golf National est prêt la rider Cup
Michel logier l'a dit se déroulera en
2018 mais le parcours est prêt il est il
est magnifique il accueille l'Alstom
Open de France tous les ans un vrai
dynamisme à 50 ans neline autour du
sport et bien d'autres choses bien sûr
la lettre Cigné par Michel logier
Jean-Lou Charon le président de la FF
golf et David appartien le président de
la F française de cyclisme et est
vraiment importante parce que tout tout
est prêt pour ces J et en cas de
candidature ce sont des équipements
existants qui ne sont pas à construire
donc pas de nouveaux investissements et
ça c'est un poid très fort et ce serait
une belle revanche aussi parce qu'on se
rappelle tout de même que le vélodrome
devait devait voir le jour dans le cadre
de cette candidature de Paris en 2012
cette fois-ci c'est exactement ça mais
grâce à la volonté des gens qui sont les
dirigeants de 50 ans Yveline des
communes qui qui composent 50 ans
nveline et bien le Vélodrome a vu le
jour grâce à la volonté de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme aussi aujourd'hui
il est là bien là et nous sommes prêts
pour l'avenir merci courtier d'être
passé sur ce plateau pour commencer à
débriefer un petit peu ces ces Mondiaux
il en sera bien évidemment encore
question tout au long de la soirée sur
TVfil dans le 78 sport à retrouver juste
après le journal mais juste pour
refermer cette séquence je vous propose
d'écouter un amateur de cyclisme c'est
l'ancien président Nicolas Sarkozi le
patron de l'UMP et qui est venu
apprécier les performances des Français
et qui lui aussi n'a pas manqué de
soutenir le dossier de Paris
2024 un équipement mondiale qui est une
réussite
exceptionnelle qu' doit à la
mobilisation de David l'appartient et
des élus qui ont fait un boulot
remarquable et vraiment pour une fois on
est candidat à des jeux olympiques avec
des infrastructures avant et non pas
après ça fait
plaisir on quitte le vélodrome national
pour évoquer les animations proposées
pendant ces vacances scolaire tout
d'abord retour sur cet atelier de manga
à la médiathèque de la verrière c'était
ce weekend les amateurs qui sont venus
chercher de précieux conseil Mélanie po
LOD
moine voilà on se rend bien compte que
c'est pas la même
chose donc leomatop ouais bien sûr elle
varie en fonction de de l'effet qu'on
veut faire
ressentir faire ressentir l'émotion
l'une des particularités du manga la BD
japonaise mais là je le lecteur est
extrêmement immergé dans le dans dans le
manga alors que dans la BD francoobelge
c'est plutôt un spectateur vu du dessus
voilà dans le manga le lecteur est dans
le manga il est avec les
personnages un simple crayon pour
débuter une feuille blanche et beaucoup
d'imagination c'est la recette du
Manga pour faire simple il faut une
histoire déjà donc avoir une histoire
une fois qu'on a l'histoire en parler
avec d'autres personnes voir si
l'histoire se tient une fois que
l'histoire se tient il y a les étapes du
dessin en lui-même donc on commence par
faire un bouillon un bouillon général de
peut-être pas de l'histoire complète
mais au moins de ce qu'on veut dessiner
une fois qu'on a le bruit on passe à une
étape qu'on appelle le crayonner ou le
crayonnage ça dépend comment on
l'appelle et pas besoin de bien savoir
dessiner un moyen d'attirer ces artistes
en
herbes j'aiis les
formes le nez les positions et le dos et
comment on place le dos je déjà lu des
livres mais c'est toujours mieux de
travailler une personne qui connait
vraiment ils sont encore loin de
réaliser des mangas entiers mais pas
d'hésitation le crayon est déjà
là une autre animation qui elle se
poursuit jusqu'à la fin des vacances
c'est à la bergerie de Rambouillet la
thématique retenue le cirque Floran
parfet LOD
moinez les stars de la journée se sont
elles ses oies ont été dressés et elles
font le spectacle pour le plus grand
bonheur des enfants le petit troupeau
partage la Vette avec les anes dans un
spectacle sur le thème du cirque où les
enfants jouent les apprentis dresseurs
j'ai pris un Anne et puis j'ai fait un
parcours d'accord c'était difficile
c'était comment c'était facile c'était
assez facile s'il était comme comme
comme une
mul faire découvrir les animaux de la
ferme autrement aux enfants c'est
l'objectif de la bergerie des oies
privoisés ça ne se voit pas tous les
jours pourant elles sont souvent
utilisées dans le dressage des chiens de
bergers il y a pas forcément d'animal
plus facile à dresser qu'un autre c'est
un travail très long et même parfois un
travail dès la naissance nos animaux
notamment des animaux pédagogiques on
les élèv dès le plus jeune âge en
présence des visiteurs donc c'est des
animaux qui sont facilement manipulables
nos anânes sont manipulés tous les jours
en présence des enfants donc c'est pour
ça aussi qu'ils sont sympas pour les
vacances scolaires des ateliers magie
d'aiguisement et jeux sont également
proposés jusqu'à la fin de la semaine il
y a pas mal de choses donc là ça ça
varie varie les plaisirs entre les
petits spectacles entre la visite des
animaux ils peuvent les toucher les
caresser c'est c'est vraiment sympa ils
sont ravis ils sont tout crottés c'est
génial hein c'était super on est venu
spécialement pour ça oui c'est très
sympathique un petit peu de tout pour
les enfants ils ont bien apprécié là
pour tous les âges 3 ans 5 ans c'était
très
sympathique avec ces 300 moutons ses 50
vaches ses chevaux et chaque saison des
petits nouveaux la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet accueille de 100000
visiteurs chaque
année et la bergerie de rambouyet qui
est présente cette année encore au salon
de l'agriculture avec quatre moutons
Mino ces 50 brebilles que peuvent
découvrir donc le public salon de
l'agriculture qui a débuté ce weekend et
on le retrouve de nombreux maréchés
éleveurs cultivateurs yvelinois TV fil
qui vous proposera une édition spéciale
de fileco ce jeudi des 18h30 en direct
c'est la fin de ce journal du lundi 23
février dans un instant sur notre
antenne le 78 sport avec michelmidoro
qui reviendra très largement sur les
résultat de ces mondiaux de cyclisme qui
viennent de se refermer à 50 ans en Ilin
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain
mardi aux mêmes horaires très bonne
soirée